the united kingdom
birthplace of the beatles and yet very
much the world's ringo
now on thursday the uk faces
an in-out referendum on whether to leave
the european union and incidentally
an in-out referendum is also what most
english people call sex
i say that was a jolly good in-out
referendum priscilla
capital staff el girl simply capital
you may not have heard about this
referendum unless you watch financial
networks where it's usually referred to
by
a catchy name there's a lot of fear out
there in the marketplace about the
brexit vote that's coming up brexit
fears gaining traction a new survey this
morning focuses on
brexit fears brexit is one of the major
concerns in the market at the moment i
think that the scariest thing about
brexit is to name brexit
because it's unknown i mean it's like
wow brexit
whoa be afraid conjuring brexit
okay calm down brexit doesn't sound
scary it just sounds like a shitty
granola bar you buy at the airport
hey this tastes like a preserved owl
pellet it i'm going to cinnabon
you pushed me into it and i know i know
if you are watching this outside the uk
you're probably thinking
why should i care about what britain
does with the eu honestly
as long as those crooked tooth scone
goblins keep shooting out royal babies
and episodes of doctor who i don't give
a tally ho
what happens there and fair enough fair
enough but
a brexit or british exit could have
wide-ranging implications both for the
uk
and the world's economy and first it
might help to understand what the
european union
actually is the idea for it came after
the second world war when there was
understandably a desire to keep the
continent
from tearing itself apart yet again and
it has since evolved into an economic
union of 28 countries
whose citizens can trade and move freely
across borders and who negotiate
international agreements
as a block but despite being a member
britain has always had an arms-length
relationship with the eu for instance it
doesn't use the euro
and some british politicians have been
openly hostile
right to the face of eu officials i
don't want to be rude
but you have the charisma of a damp rag
and the appearance of a low-grade bank
clerk
and the question that i want to ask that
we're all going to ask is
who are you i've never heard of you
nobody in europe had ever heard of you
that
is painful to watch and not just because
all of those insults are things people
in the uk have said about me
and and look look the eu is not perfect
it's large confounding and relentlessly
bureaucratic
think of it like gerard depardieu it's
an unwieldy european body that's a
source of great bewilderment
but britain leaving it would be a huge
destabilizing decision so you would
expect
the brexit camp to have some pretty
solid arguments unfortunately
many of them are one of the
most popular involves the financial
contributions that britain makes to the
eu
we've got a once in a lifetime
opportunity to take back control in this
country of huge sums of money
that we send every year to brussels
about 350 million pounds a week
we do not control that is former london
mayor boris johnson
a man with both the look and the
economic insight of bam bam from the
flintstones
he he has even been driven around in a
giant red
bus for the last month with the words we
send the eu
350 million pounds a week written on the
side
but that number has been thoroughly
debunked it's actually about 190 million
pounds a week when you consider a rebate
the uk receives and other money that the
eu sends back
on top of which if britain does leave
the eu it may have to spend close to
that amount
just to access the common market so what
the bus should really say is
we actually send the eu 190 million
pounds a week which is a proportion of
our gdp makes sound fiscal sense
in fact considering the benefits we reap
in return oh we're running out of
bus
okay bye bye now
what one of the other uh main talking
points from pro brexit campaigners has
been the eu's onerous regulations
it's even a centerpiece of the
feature-length pro-brexit movie
brexit the movie here is regulated eu
man
waking from his regulated slumber to
start his regulated day
you wouldn't think you'd need a law for
pillar cases but the eu has
five but that's nothing the pillow
inside is subject to 109 different
eu laws but is it though because
we blew up that frame and then went
looking through each of the pillow
regulations they feature
and the problem is most have nothing to
do with actual pillows for instance
this one is a classification of a type
of breakfast cereal
that comes in pillow shapes this one is
related to a merger between two auto
part companies that included the phrase
pillow ball joints
and finally this one uses the word
pillow in reference to this
weird foot pump thing which is
supposedly for inflating air mattresses
but is clearly a sex doll for a platypus
it's so obvious what that actually
is so it seems
the benefits of leaving may be
overstated and there is
many there's a great many people warning
about a real downside
president obama is against britain
leaving so is china
so is japan so is india and the eu
itself in fact one austrian politician
tried to convince britain not to leave
with a poem
the brexit is to put it simple not like
an ordinary pimple you take some cream
you put it on a few days later
it is gone it is a complicated matter
more like a novel not a letter
to understand the story well you've got
to listen i will tell you what may
happen
so sit back and let me wrap it
cool i mean come on britain
if a middle aged austrian bureaucrat
spitting dope half rhymes in a busy
hallway
if he does not win you over nobody will
but you know what there's also
overwhelming consensus about the damage
britain could do to its economy by
leaving
reports by groups like the british
treasury the bank of england
the imf the oecd the national institute
of economic and social research
pricewaterhousecoopers oxford economics
and the center for economic performance
have all predicted that leaving would
have a negative effect
on the british gdp and the pro-brexit
camps response to that has not been
great
i think the people in this country have
had enough of experts
with uh organizations from acronyms
from organizations with acronyms saying
that they know what is best in getting
it consistently wrong
yes these eggheads with their
studies and degrees
i get my economic forecast from clever
otis the gdp predicting horse
and at this point you may be wondering
if leaving is so universally seen as a
bad idea
then who the is in favor of it well
let me introduce you to one of the
leading groups backing at brexit
the uk independence party also called
ukip their leader is nigel farage that
man you saw earlier at the comedy
central roast of european council
president hermann van rompuy
ukip is known for its hard-line
anti-immigration views and some of its
members have engaged in
outright racism just look at robert blay
a ukip candidate for parliament who was
suspended
after a tabloid paper caught him saying
this about a rival of sri lankan descent
the family's only been here since the
70s you're not british
whoa there just hold up not british
enough to be in our parliament
he's talking about a british citizen who
was born in london
and raised in hampshire how is that not
british enough
must he literally be a monocled badger
named reginald who lives in a shepherd's
pie
is that the bar of entry to him
and at the local level ukip has had
councillors like this woman who served
on a district council in
kent i have to watch my tongue because i
can be very outspoken
and it goes against grain the only
people i do have problems with
are negroes and i don't
know why okay okay
let's agree it is now official not
everything sounds smarter in a british
accent
it's official now it is absolutely
100 official i
i know i know what you heard is
horrifying but at least we can all rest
easy knowing that as she speaks
that shelf full of clowns is plotting to
carry her away
into the night forever but even when
ukip candidates
are caught making racist comments farage
has sometimes stood by them look at
kerry smith
who used a racial slur about chinese
people a term that i'm not going to use
because
i'm not a parliamentary candidate for
ukip but nigel farage did not exactly
condemn him
if you and your mates are going out for
chinese what do you say you're going for
i honestly would not use the word a lot
of people would would you
no but a lot of people would yeah a lot
of people would
uh racist for example uh bigots idiots
the intolerance who am i missing here
oh yeah ukip voters them as well a lot
of people would
now ukip argued that a brexit would
enable the uk to significantly reduce
immigration preventing both eu citizens
from taking british jobs
and non-eu citizens from sneaking in to
commit terror attacks and they
have not been subtle in their campaign
with toxic posters
like this one showing lines of refugees
and the headline breaking point
it is hard for me to overstate to you
how poisonous things have become in
england
just this week mp joe cox was killed in
the street
and the man charged for it gave his name
in court as death to traitors
freedom for britain and in that cauldron
people are being asked to make a major
political decision
and incidentally regarding immigration
even if you believe
tightening borders is what britain needs
to do you should know that opting out of
the eu
will not necessarily enable britain to
do that
leaving the eu does that mean the uk
gets control of its borders
um it could do if we were to completely
cut ourselves off from the rest of
europe we could certainly choose to
end migration from eu but if we want to
remain part of the single market that
means accepting free mobility of labor
both into and out of the uk of course
because if britain wants a good trade
deal with the eu it's probably going to
have to abide by most of its rules
and the same goes by the way for all
those hypothetically cumbersome
non-pillow-related pillow regulations
because if british companies want to
trade with the eu
they also are likely to have to go to
have to abide by those rules anyway so
it's not a brexit so much as it's a
bratus quo
or a bromeostasis or a conscious
unbruckling
so to recap immigration policy may not
change
hysteria over regulation is a red
herring the costs of membership are
reasonable
and the economic benefits of staying
appear to outweigh the costs and yet
polls suggest my homeland is on the edge
of doing something absolutely
insane and on some level i actually kind
of understand
because there is an innate british
desire
to tell europe to go itself i feel
it too you know those things i say when
countries pop up over my shoulder
that's a reflex action i don't even know
i'm doing it
i'll show you um germany where the
national motto is
let's stick to the present shall we uh
okay uh
give me another one uh luxembourg what
happens when you leave lichtenstein out
in the sun too long
bam okay give me another one belgium the
casual acquaintance france crops out of
his instagram photos
okay okay one more i'm on a roll one
more denmark
what would happen if a suicide note was
a country i don't even know
i'm doing these and i could do them all
day
and to be honest the eu does not make
itself easy to love
its official anthem is beethoven's ode
to joy and they actually had a
competition to do
a video set to that tune and you really
have to see
what one
yourself right now
you see it is perfectly understandable
to be annoyed
at europe i'm barely containing my anger
right now
but here is how i feel about the eu it's
a complicated
bureaucratic ambitious overbearing
inspirational
and consistently irritating institution
and britain would be absolutely
crazy to leave it especially because if
it stays
it can reap all the benefits while still
being a total dick about everything
and that is the british way
so to the people of the uk i say this
if you need your hatred of the eu h
scratched
i understand but please don't vote for a
brexit on thursday
i have a better solution i'd like to
retroactively enter that eu anthem
contest
with a song straight out of every
british heart that both relently
relentlessly insults europe and quietly
acknowledges
how lost we'd be without it please enjoy
we are the united kingdom
you can eat or spot the dicks
that being said we're not going to leave
you
turns out we need you nonetheless
is far too hot
but we must admit without
these
would all countries but crazy
if we voted here